スカンクの匂いがアパートに入れて
でもさ、なんでスカンクの匂いだってわかったの?
見てたの?襲われるところ
アメリカに出てスカンクがいっぱいいる
いっぱいいね、このボストンのアパートの外に
公園から出られるじゃない?
ところが、すっごい綺麗なこの
私としてすっごい綺麗なの?
すごい綺麗なの?
すごい臭いんだ
私のボタンク
私としては1階1階
4階1階もアパートがあった
3枚で、この2人ともホテルに出てきました
そんなに匂い取れないのね
犬自身は匂いはどうなんですか?
鼻が敏感だから
スカンクがこの匂いをエスプレイしました
犬が逃げて、アパートに入って
全部のアパートの建物が
犬が浴びたそのまま
犬が、アパートに入って、かわいそうだったね
自然自分の体からスカンクの匂いが
ね、だって
向こうは寄せ付けないための匂いだから
よかった、日本はスカンクいないでよかったよね
いないのかな?
いないね
聞いたことない、見たことない
でもこういう、再建する
そうそう、ガラエキ
アライグマ
アライグマはいるー
家だって、大変だったんだって
大変だったんだって
小田道のお家
うちの庭にも、埼玉の
アライグマ
アライグマって、なんか
アライグマ可愛い
可愛いですね
可愛い
可愛いんだけど
猫とか襲っちゃうし
凶暴なんだよね
アライグマ、ラスカルのイメージで
それ、なんで見たんですか
うちの庭にいたんですけど
アライグマって、どれくらいだな
猫一回り
尻尾がこんな
可愛いですよ
一応、なんか雰囲気が可愛いですね
だけど、結構怖いですね
野生のやつなんですよね
空き家にね、住みついて
へー
うちの隣の家はね、屋根の裏に
巣作っちゃって、子供産んじゃくて
子供産じゃ